THE CAPITOL INSURRECTIN,
WHSI
TOP AIDE WHED THEY
IT?
NGEY ARE Z IN WITHON FRIDAY  DI
ESENCE OWHITE
ALIST GROUPS AND PEN CHA
STRATEGYT E CONVENTION
>> AND F AL NONG MAROMMITTEETOM
THEY'RE STILRYO  THOSE PERSONAI
THPRESIDENT OF THE UNIATES AND E
VEO TO--
THATLL I T T INDICTED
ACTUALESLY WILL DECI TM.TH
TTEE? DO YOU THINK
TURD  DOCUMENWE D KNOWHN
DOCU TURNED OVER TO  HIM NOT GI
T ACCOUNT OF WHAT HAEDE WAA CEN.
ITH THE PRESIDENT AS THEY h APWA
KING TBE EXPVE
MMTHISK
LOOF US WHO WATCHED THESIONS ONA
WHILE, WE NEVER GHHE
FULLY.OF SHOWING T, JUST DOING
SAY, LOOK, I TRIED TO MP
UNREASONABLE
'M NOTNG TIN TERMS OACTUALLY GES
JUST HELD INT BY
CONGRESS FOR N C  SUBPOENA, HIS
FOR SUMMER.
JAAR6t
TH BPUBLICANS
PROBABLY FLIP HOUSE
ONCEUT
THE TR IN CONTEMPT, ITWILL TAKE,
EAL HIS TRIS UNDER WAY.
TH D HELP THCOITHEY'REINP
RE ELECTIONS. BER 2022 MAY BE  .
L SE IT IS WRAPPED UP
BEFORE THEN.
WE WILL SEE  H
IN THE EFFORT TO OVERTURN THE
TR
AUELLIS, WHO SAID THOSORED LAST,
FU
ITE HOUSTH
WHRE SOUND ATHE TIHOW SIGNIFICA?
D THE T NOARE ALREADY KNEW OR AT
CURTAID SEE BACK IN ARY,
WE WERE ALNUM
JANU
PUBL OTY MH IN PLI
PUEARANC, TELE ANCES,TI LOOK, WE
IS DOING IS TRYIPUFI TR TRAIL A
NE AS POSSLET WE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, FME
PRESIDEN GETTING ADERS D ADVISE
GE
THATHEULY THINGS
LEGISLATIVELY, THEY COULTR
IN SECRETARY O
STATES' OFFICES, TY COULD USLEGO
TR CHALLENGE THIS. IE MAY CONTI
F THISRE
ALL OF
PRLITICS. OUT IN THE GEORGIA GOS
PERDRMER SENATOR WHO
LOST I CHALLNG
AND HE'S MAKINCLAIM KEMP
IS THE REASO LOST TEE KEMPCERTIN
VICTORCAN LOE.EDHI THIS IS
WH --
>> I ST. ALL WANT THE ENDORSEME
TRUMP.
YOU REMEMBER FOR YEARS HRD
THE EXPRESSION, ANE PAPEIT
D HIS WHOLE  ONG AND IT'S A VER
NT TREASURE.
>> A VERY IMPORTANTRDAVID PERDU
T RACE
ELECTION WD STOL
IN RUNOFF AND HERE'SE PO
O WANT ENDTHE THINGS PILING UP,D
BLAMHEN KEMPNDING OVER THEPOWER
WE WILL IFS UT FORMER PRESIDT
TRMAINS AT THE CENTER OF
THE VORTEX OF REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES.
SO EVERYONE WANTS HIENDORSEMENT.
HE'SOL HE
SAID HOUGH HEWETDAY.
IT AY
TS
>>S ENDORS M 8
S,MEEFORE THAL CRUX OF THE
P PRIMAR